12 متر عن اضافيا من نوع سيزاركس ستسلمه
فرنسا لك يافا هدف اعلن عنه وزير الجيوش
الفرنسي سيباستيانو على اثر لقائه بنظيره
الاوكراني
عقيدتنا العسكريه واضحه لا شيئا يعد من
المحظورات وزير الدفاع الاوكراني جاء مع
جزء من هيئه اركانه العامه لعرض احتياجات
الجيش بما فيها احتياجات قطاع الطيران
وعلى عكس الولايات المتحده اكدت فرنسا
استعدادها الاستجابه لطلب اوكرانيا وانها
لا تستبعد تزويدك هذا الطائرات المقاتله
[موسيقى]
فيديو سكاست ناقشنا نموذج اعتمادي
الطائرات المقاتله كم منصه لم نناقش
الطراز او العلامه التجاريه ناقشنا كيفيه
اعتماد منصه طيران لتعزيز قدراتنا في
الدفاع عن مجالنا الجوي
لاوكرانيا
عسكريه جماعه معهد الاقتصاد العالمي
للاستشارات